so do you feel that your ethnicity
prevents you from certain rules
sometimes because i mean like there's a
lot of people that are saying like oh
asians are getting more in but then you
have to remember there's
such a big wide range of asians you have
chinese vietnamese
thailand filipino that's a lot
but i mean like you can't just put it to
one
there's so so many different types but i
mean like i hope like i have it in just
because
a lot of filipinos do look mexican and
sometimes they do look for that mexican
role
so i mean like i think i probably have a
better chance than
i mean filipinos have a better chance
than other asians but at the same time
you have to weigh it out because
they also want chinese you know i mean
they always want the chinese trick
family role too
so i think having this ethnicity that i
have is a bit
bit difficult to get in like um acting
and everything
but just as an example i've had meetings
with agents or have had
managers tell me that agents won't see
me because
they already have an asian guy you know
that's just one example
where you're allowed to have all kinds
of different white
women and white men but you're allowed
to have one asian girl and one asian guy
you know
and my manager has tried to convince
agents to say hey listen he's a little
bit different or he's this and that
but they're like well we already have an
asian guy and that asian guy can pretty
much do
everything you know so and so you know
finding representation has been
really kind of an interesting journey um
so that's similar to casting
you know um i do a lot of theater
and and that's certainly been the case
where
they talk about diversity casting um
but you know signing the check is a
different
is a different animal you know to get
them to actually like
sign on the dotted line to say i want to
cast you that's a bigger decision
so they're all very a lot of them are
very interested in
meeting you and and seeing your shows
um but to actually you know cast an
asian american lead
um in a role that's not written for an
asian american
or in a play that's not about the you
know um
i is an identity you know driven piece
um it's a it's a different it's a
different dialogue
you know because you know it's like if
you have
i mean it's if you have you have a show
that's like at four different
you know white men and women and you
have one minority then it's like okay
well that's
that's good but then if you suddenly
have you know
three minorities and one white guy then
it's like is this
is this story about race is a story
about black people or asian people
you know um i think that lingers in the
back of a lot of people's minds i don't
think they're
it's as on the surface but
as a minority i certainly see
kind of hints of that you know that that
that
they're almost afraid to make things too
ethnic or too cultural
um as opposed to no it's just an
american story yes
um especially in the in the non-union
section of work just because
a lot of like student films and
low-budget movies always look for the
all-american type which is either
black or white and i'm neither so it's
like really hard
to go out for that or actually not hard
i can't just go out for that role
because it's just like you know we need
a white
blonde skinny female or we need you know
the typical ghetto black
girl and it's just like you know i can't
do
so yeah um yes i do think that uh i'm
kind of limited in my roles as
african-american
and as a female you're not going to have
a lot of roles
that are just written for you i get a
lot of that
and so i'm like well how do i break into
the industry you know i'm
african-american
i'm young and i'm a female no no no well
what's the yes
so i i've been focusing on that and i
feel like
there are rules for me and i've been
seeing a lot more
roles come out for me and it's not
necessarily
the main character but i'm here doing
what i love to do so it's not about
being the main character for me it's
about
you know doing what i love to do making
a living
out of it and just enjoying my job